no signori distrare calo registrare per
registrare ok soprattutto sono pronto
sono pronto
sono pronto sono pronto sarà stanco
è la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e questo è il
primo video che faccio di ritorno dalle
vacanze ragazzi sono tornato ieri
veramente non vedevo l'ora di iniziare
perché tanto siamo su happy visto anche
se non è domenica perché durante le
vacanze mi avete fracassato le balle sul
fatto che è uscito un nuovo personaggio
e non vedo l'ora di vedere che cazzo i
ragazzi ieri comincerà il 3 con un
flight school
non so da un pezzo di trovarlo subito il
personaggio nuovo ma tanto durante il
video vi sicuro uscirà anche me il
cagnolino credo che ti chiamerò fido che
fido avanti che break perfetto e
addestratissimi il mio cane fantasticato
ball anche che cazzo sta facendo
perfetta la ragazza evitate di mettere
le delle crocchette dei cani degli
stupefacenti perché finiscono malissimo
tipo questo tratto ragazzi non ho mai
visto un cane con un'acconciatura così
sexy
l'altro chamber ragazzi va camion
ragazzi la camera di tortura non poteva
mancare al mio ritorno maledizione
questa si chiama cooler 2000 e della
pulizia del buco del ca pranzi credo che
sia una cosa si vede te molto igienica
come cosa
i ragazzi invece ho regalato un
bellissimo tavolo da massaggio avete
presente quando vi stiracchiate la
mattina benissimo sta cosa fa tutto da
sé e di stiracchia come dio comanda
dov'è il personaggio nuovo che ne so che
di cache di apple mandiamo così gravi e
questo per il distretto 12 ma [ __ ]
mi ha stimolato ok mi è cresciuto un
pene anche se piccolo no fermo l'ho
mancato non mancato se è una fossa di
pressing della madonna
ciao
raga l'ultima volta che ho giocato un
volto aveva stravinto spero di fare lo
stesso buon ritorno
devo riuscire si ok adesso dove centrale
il wing prima che non c'entro ci vorrà
un secolo ma [ __ ] ragazzi non
aspettate avevo vinto che cazzo fa non
ti permetto di scendere [ __ ] anche
effettivamente vado a cagare in questo
modo e questo e questo ragazzo ho
trovato è lui il personaggio nuovo una
ragazzina fegato incredibile come
siccome faccia comandarlo devo andare
avanti ma che cazzo pioggia ti amo non
so chi sei ma ti amo da morire a 30
maledetto trita come si deve anche babbo
natale non se lo merita non solo me ma
bravo che cos'è sta roba
ancora non ho capito bene come si
comanda effettivamente mai così shop in
the pool tuffo in piscina ragazzi
minchia se sto tizio si tuffa in piscina
secondo me esplode tutto dovete
ammettere che indossa una maglietta
talmente sexy che manco armani farebbe
una cosa del genere comunque mai così
devo minchia che tu ragazzi questo lode
qualcosa mettetevi al sicuro
ok sono esploso praticamente solo io
perfetto
devo riuscire a perfetto questo è il
tuffo morto se non hai non dà segni di
vita lascia in faccia ai 300 km all'ora
perfetto
ai ragazzi è impossibile vincere questa
cosa io ve lo dico già mi sembra mi
sembra assurdo non ci provo lo stesso
ok è andata di culo in una maniera
incredibile ma ce l'ho fatta gatti sono
carico per cento il prossimo
devono aspettarsi può fare anche con lui
e questo sarà l'impossible più difficile
della storia tra l'altro ho perso
effettivamente non pensavo di vincere
invece quanto la figura del [ __ ] ma
stavolta ci devo provare con lui regala
aspettate un attimo allora piano piano
ho detto piano ma affanculo allo ragazzi
devo riuscire a fermi fermi fermi ok no
no no no non loro per piano via sono vi
vostro ragazzi ricordatevi nelle
situazioni milioni di non perdere la
testa sul caso su canova che questo
ragazzi lo faccio consiglio perché anche
lui ha bisogno della sua parte poverino
hi sim fai vedere chi sei più cazzuto di
un elicottero che possiamo fare vai così
a troy up date un attimo sono sono
diventato una rana perfetto interjet
test che si sta parlando con nonno ciak
e da un secolo che non vado un jet
pronti per il decollo 3 2 1
e sempre stato no poi bellissimo in modo
in cui guida nonno cia che tipo buon
volo a tutti i ragazzi
ok come non detto no no devi andare di
là devi andare di là maledetto nonna
aveva da piedi mi sa che faccio prima
con mi vado a schiantare contro muro
senza motivo vai non ho uno short fondi
le facciamo se riesco a fare un livello
decente dove questo era tutto calcolato
ragazzi lo sapevo non vi preoccupate
anche questa è una calcolatissimo tutto
calcolato tutto quanto ragazzi degli
occhi o dammi la mano
ok da dammi una testa più che altro se
riesci mai così ha vinto ha vinto york
ha vinto ha vinto gli occhi non si sa
come lei crash cos'è sta roba ragazzini
che crolla poiché aereo perfetto mi sono
salvato in una maniera incredibile
salve c'è nessuno alla finestra e se per
caso mi dà per un aiutino non è che mi
dispiace ragazzo scivolando aiuto
qualcuno mi aiuti posta
sono caduto in una piscina delle palline
che bello ho sempre desiderato sguazzare
in un box ok sono sono vivo sono vivo
sono vivo buongiorno senta ma [ __ ]
pure a lei ho vinto canyon make it
perfetta ragazzi mi piace di titoli così
i frazionisti che hanno a prescindere ma
io ce la faccio con un elicottero raga
sono troppo potente troppo potente
troppo modesta ancora fa by crossgate
ragazzi non ce la faccia anche centa è
maschi dai così
c'è il film non ci credo ho vinto ho
vinto così ho vinto ho vinto così potevo
giocare dei miei livelli perché
veramente un secolo che non approva il
corso dei miei livelli
location forse facciamo questo la
perfetta
devo lanciare mia moglie e io devo
lanciare mia moglie su un coltello che
colpisce non ciak oppure ucciso mia
moglie poi poi poi la uso come come come
gratta schiena client seven fa vj ora
facciamo così con l'elicottero perché
devo salvare per salvare non lo so che
non fermi fermi che devo salvare in 1
sack fermi allora nonno alza la sbarra
che ti alziamo ragazzi è no vabbè non
quella sbarra non per fermi un attimo
non so che cazzo sta succedendo allora
non devi andare allora non facciamo così
io ti porto in sala ok non è successo
nulla
sei ancora tutto l'intero meno male
allora dobbiamo andare avanti pia
abbastanza piano da non farti perfetto
armi beh no
cazzo sono diventate una pignatta
maledizione alla facciamo facciamo così
diversamente proviamo a tirarlo su dalla
barba no no no dove vai
il mio elicottero è il mio elicottero
stronzo dove favola sto bastardo che si
diverte senza di me praga è no no non ci
prendere tanto gusto e minigonna
ma guarda lì che schiaccia la testa ce
l'abbiamo importante che presto troppo
ero qui va bene e io io io lascio quello
che mi è rimasto ok bene con un aspetto
ci vado io in barella turno 21 ragazzi
direi concludere qui l'episodio è
comunque ricordatevi di mettere il nome
del personaggio in nei commenti e io
vedo di scegliere il migliore
ragazzi se video è piaciuto come al
solito lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook come non i
video trovate nella descrizione essere
prescritti iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo
il prossimo video bene ragazzi